the first industrial revolution starts
in many places
but one of them is cornwall in 1712 atop
a mine
with a man named thomas newcomen
newcomen was an iron monger
and a preacher and a man who
occasionally
helped save miners from the bottom of
flooded mines
it's in that latter context that he
helped come up with the idea of the
atmospheric engine
which is really the prototype of all
steam engines to follow
he was an inventor and an innovator and
in 1712 he took a whole lot of other
people's
ideas and built them into a single
object it was two stories high
it was loud it consumed everything
around it water and coal
and it also changed everything too it
took a while before anyone worked out
just what a powerful
object this was it's 20 years before you
get to 100 of these objects in
circulation it's nearly 100 years before
you get to 2000
but in that slow steady ramp of the
atmospheric
engine with watts transformations in it
into the steam
engine what you see is an object that
moves from mines
into factories and changes the way
factory work is done
it changes the possibilities of how
things can be built
it makes a series of complicated
cultural and practical transformations
but in some ways the most important
moment of scale isn't that first century
but the second
and it comes in 1829 at a place called
rain hill in england
when a locomotive called the rocket
changes
the way we thought about steam engines
they go from being stationary to mobile
they go from being powerful to being
fast
and in so doing unleash the possibility
of creating networks of trains and
railway systems
but to get to a railway system required
more than just a locomotive
it required regulation regulation that
fixed
train prices so that everyone could have
access to the technology
that managed safety so that the trains
didn't hurt people
that changed the ideas about how time
should be configured so the trains would
run on time
it took ideas about timetables ideas
about
who had rights in land it took
regulations
it took all kinds of new practitioners
ticket takers
and safety inspectors and civil
engineers
and those train systems unfolded in
britain
and the united states and australia and
japan
and india and in so doing transformed
the way we thought about
time and distance and about speed
the irony of course in all of this is
that industrial revolution
was nearly two centuries in the making
so getting to scale in this instance
took time and it required all manner
of regulations and social actors and
practice
to be accomplished